[Music]
I know it's gonna be an easy one trust
me
this is gonna be Bill O'Reilly right
nope nope nope nope nope
he's answering comments again
[Music]
so let's get after it and
happen [__] bread he's gonna be
answering questions are we going to get
a little bit enough about the [__]
bird already that would be great but if
somebody did ask him a question that I
feel it was one of us because something
we bring up ready for this one here we
go ever after this and see what it is
that makes them the same indifference
from you or me from that same episode
miles Holburn writes Chris tone down the
tough guy routine it's not age
appropriate
many I know find you talented but are
grossed out by a quote Old unquote man
sounding like a teenager dude I love
that even the producer has to say quote
um also
hey you know you notice you notice Chris
is falling into one of those trappings
of the internet where yeah he's they're
focusing on the negative comments I know
it's tough it happens in some people I
don't care anymore I ignore him but no I
don't even read me neither I'm saying I
won't I'm ignoring actually I take that
back you know where I do read comments
on the bad luck boys Channel because
they go oh look at a kitty that's
positive
how old is this guy uh they don't
there's no way
do you think that you get a [__] do
you think that you get an entire
background report on every single person
that leaves a YouTube comments
oh you know what who's this guy where's
he live let's dox him
[Laughter]
he starts getting it hey you know what
let's start a Discord we'll start doing
gay ops Oh forget about this thing
called chaops
unless their age just an avatar of the
letter M okay I don't know I'm gonna be
who I want to be and how I wanna be uh
and you know if you don't like somebody
being tough it's about you not them and
I don't think that I think you're
missing the point Chris nobody thinks
you're tough that's the it's he
literally said tough guy routine which
is to imply that you're not a tough guy
he doesn't even take an insult like his
brain is so incapable of self can we
please have you can't even take a
critical comment that's critical he's
like yeah well you know what some guys
are just tough guys what are you gonna
do about it I would love nothing more
than Dan bongino he'll have a boxing
match nothing more in my life that I
would want Pat bongino just [__] beat
the living [__] out of critical it's
like hey uh you know maybe you should
stop talking about how big your dick is
you know uh many people say if you keep
talking about how big your dick is uh
you probably have a small dick what do
you say Chris hey you know some guys
have a huge [__] what do you want or or
no first he would go how big is that
guy's [__] yeah I'll be exactly I want
to see his dick let me put it in my
mouth a little bit
he did the woman thing bro he [__] he
said [__] hey stop with the tough guy
[__] and just think I'm tough I think
I'm tall I'm pretty you think I'm pretty
yeah thank you I appreciate the
compliment next comment next question
he's incapable of processing the
criticism I love it
oh [__] yeah king of King about yet he
goes Chris is real tough on pigeons
uh I got the biggest body count uh and
everybody in my neighborhood in terms of
birds
uh yeah I got like 600 they have zero
yeah you know what 26 confirmed avian
kills
I'm not here to please
I prefer to say Al Dente hold on
hold on do you hear what he just said to
his audience by the way get out of
broadcasting this the only the videos
that do best for him is when he reads
comments the rest of them just got like
a 1K it's pretty funny because if people
want to see him be made fun of yeah he's
learning and he's doing here's the thing
he's becoming beholden to whatever the
algorithm like likes the most so he's
pulling a Kevin Brennan right now he's
just a hostage of his own like I just
need to make money here not them and oh
also Chris I have a question because I
learned a little bit over the weekend
um about the winner workings at YouTube
so is there any chance that you called
your person over there YouTube and said
hey get these Revengers if this guy's
[__] out of my algorithm
just that's what we think just curious
you have no proof but it's what we think
happened
uh I'm not here to please you I'm not
here to fit your expectation of what you
want me to be oh no no no please I never
want please please Chris I want you to
hear this please I never want you to
change no please never change
it yeah we I all want please stay
exactly how you are I don't want you to
be different because you're not a dude
that makes me mad there's people that we
cover that make me angry right he
doesn't make he's not dating hyper they
never must be mad he just he's so fun
he's so fun to watch because he's a you
know I'm gonna say he's a big galoot you
know he's a big galoot I gotta say this
Chris if you ever ever
uh discover the concept of
self-awareness our show is [__] we're
done we have a whole segment oh Michael
Strahan yeah that's all we got left
uh what's in that for me you can never
make people happy you're all definitely
not CNN you can never by the way this is
I love it you could never make me more
happy listen to that phrase it's not
like he said you can't you can't please
everyone right like that's a normal
thing you can never make anyone I can
never make anyone happy not even my wife
that's nuts
oh [__] the only person I can make Camp
is my mother
[Music]
and then in the chat he's just do not
that's exactly oh [__] man they're not
for me you can never make people happy
you're all looking to take people down
I'm not looking to Take You Down Chris
all of everyone everyone's looking to
destroy me she's still getting he's
stuck at the end of good fella he's
looking for black helicopters while he's
in the car
jumping the fires playing yeah
see there it is oh God damn yeah you're
right
uh that's the currency for two kid in a
wheelchair stirring the sauce while he's
[__] look at helicopters Hawaii his
wife's asking him we couldn't leave the
guns at your mother's house she flushes
all the steroids because the cops come
always like that's all the steroids we
had Karen Karen and just like in
Goodfellas like Ray Leonard characters
he would be sobbing about it of course
his tea levels would be dropping yeah
plummeting that was all the testosterone
I had Karen
oh [__] man
many in our culture not everybody but
way too many oversampled on social media
and I don't care if people think I'm
talented yes you do that's all you do
everybody knows you do it's the it's the
it's literally the foundation of your
existence
it what it's what defines you
I am talented
no you're not at what
what are you good at no honestly like
that would be my next question Chris God
started people like me I'm good at
holding a bird but if Royce said hey I
know I'm good at what I do then you go
oh really how like Royce could not tell
off a list of things that he's good at
right same thing with me if I said I'm
good at this you go get really at what
there's a couple things I could go yeah
I'm pretty I'm pretty funny I'm pretty
good at this kind of stuff whatever I
would love to ask Chris what are you
good at what are you good at besides
sitting at a desk having some young
person bring you coffee and then reading
off a teleprompter holding a bird
walking and talking he could do that
he's a good walker talker bread makes a
mean garlic bread
um he calls his mother
laughs
hey
oh [__]
I'm good at this job
[Laughter]
I just started being a podcast for like
three months ago wait I don't even have
a job you're a free agent listen free
agent
I'm good at this job I've been doing it
for 12 years what do you do
worked at it for a really long time but
I think about it is right he is very
good at prop comedy remember the giant
oh yeah hey hey he's good at prop comedy
with the Q-tips remember the Q-tips
all right he's a funny guy with the
Q-tips that are the big one yeah big old
nose yeah it was funny and work on it in
ways that I think okay I'm gonna get to
the next because we can spend a bunch of
time on this because he talks about it
for like all too long now Mercer I'm
gonna give you some options we have
workout routine but before you say yes
we have Joe Rogan and that seems to be
the longest segment
ah
I don't know man workout routine sounds
like it'll be hilarious to me but the
Joe Rogan sounds like it'd be even fun I
mean ah work yeah we gotta do work come
on here we go an episode of Cuomo on the
couch this is from the different place
different space for Matt Carruthers hey
Chris I'm glad you're doing these Cuomo
on the couch episodes your modesty is
very inspiring
that's a [__] show
Bessie was that you pessie did you set a
fake account did you [__] with us is
that you he's just so humble guys
which one of you was that which one of
you in the chat did that come on man
somebody asked me that Carruthers does
sound very similar yeah
okay let's see
I was wondering what would you recommend
for losing about 20 pounds in the next
couple of months do you have any
particular high intensity interval
training routines that you do I've done
some but want something different hope
you keep up these podcasts take care of
yourself yeah uh burn more calories than
you eat and lift heavy things next
question this shouldn't be too [__]
deep eat less move more okay okay fair
hate fair enough
and you'll lose weight
if that's the goal
is literally just to see the numbers on
the scale come down but now he's going
to tell you about he that's not what
it's about for him what's about for him
is definition
striations on his triceps
take out sugar and booze hold on calm
down [__] you first calm down out of
your diet
adopt the understanding that dessert is
for children
ew what what a [__] [__] of what a
miserable contest man tiramisu what am I
a [__] toddler [__] out of here get
out of you oh you want me to have
tiramisu what am I half a fact or
something first off if your chocolate
may as well have a dick in my ass
[Laughter]
I don't I don't [__] with I don't [__]
that way could you imagine being like
friends with someone I've never heard
that before and you go like I get it I I
will say this adults should not be
ordering dessert all the time I order I
order I ordered a sharing one and eat it
there by myself and make everybody wait
and watch me and I won't share it do you
want a bunch of spoons let me get four
brownie all alone thank you and they go
how many spoons one one thing one how
many spoons not but it's like could you
imagine being out to dinner a group of
people whatever and then they're like
hey would you guys like a little dessert
or something and
desert is for children
[__] man
I'm in New York I'm
like I want cake I don't know that was
that wasn't like responses usually no
you know I would love to but you know
what I'm saving the calories for the
booze tonight yeah thank you you know
something like that
it's for [__] children [__]
ing wife is a pedophile
exactly
why are you so mad you're implying that
my wife
yeah my wife saw me eating a brownie the
other day and then she had sex with me
wouldn't she some kind of sick [__] look
if you eat an ice cream if you're eating
ice cream cone you might as well deep
throat it because you're
oh this is ice cream cones your boy Joe
Biden there Chris yeah he does he says
well he's to be fair his brain is not
like as that of a child now uh apathetic
Crow you guys are just uh intimidated by
Cuomo's Talent are you are you even
thinking for free and then whoa fifty
dollars from Bob Dole I don't know if
that's a real Bob Dole because he's dead
but I sub to you guys during the
election first time Dono today's episode
with Trump and Cuomo feel like deja vu
you guys are [__] hilarious as always
stay and he became a monthly supporter
thank you so much Bob Dole Bob Dole I
think it should be noted that Bob Dole
although he is dead he only died like a
year and a half I know he lived for a
long time in there yeah
um and move more pay attention to your
steps I don't know your particular
energy or I don't know if you're a fat
piece of [__] who [__] deep throats
cannolis like a fat so I don't know what
it is you do you know
why I can only shape that way what are
they what are they what are they what
are they implying what are they trying
to do what are they trying to get it to
get in my head but Gay Thoughts now no
thank you no [__] thank you
I can't why is he so mad I'm so glad we
did this I know I know I'm glad
I'm really glad too yeah it was a good
one this is so good
okay so um that one now now the next
one's a Joe Rogan one this is from the
episode of you reacting to YouTube
comments 2020 writes I have to be honest
with you I never used to really like you
when you were on CNN I can't actually
believe I'm watching your podcast now
and I'm usually the Joe Rogan type
podcast person but I'm actually really
surprised great job who did this come on
guys who's guessing this guy up which
one of you guys are guessing about yeah
whoever is using this tact is really
smart yeah you're really good because
this is a brilliant way to get them I
mean that that is uh very high praise
because it speaks to a very rare comedy
uh commodity which is the ability to be
open-minded and to change your opinion I
mean that is a really good question when
I think of open-minded willing to change
his opinion I think Chris Cuomo yeah
these these days they call them all
amenable Chris yeah I [__] think of
the most hard-headed grease ball from
[__] CNN's past days yeah seriously
and you know it's always a little
difficult for me when I hear somebody
say I didn't like you
um because you know even if you're on TV
every day and you're talking about
things I it's really hard for me to
believe that I know any of the people
that I see on television
I think I don't find myself to be very
performative I mean you know Greg both
are entertaining and for being honest
we're talented better because he watches
that's not true I take that back you are
entertaining but not in the way you
think you're entertaining people yeah
you're unintentionally in entertaining
right you're like the rumoredemic you
know laughing at you right you're the
joke
you're you're entertaining in the way
that like when you feed a cat that has
palsy yeah exactly
High School named Danny and like we
would all like goof on him and [__] but
like because we let them hang around us
like he thought we thought he was cool
right we were all laughing at him
because he was [__] merch for you
Danny
[Laughter]
because we're we're in the apartment
together
um but your brain is out of the boxer
from Death to smoochie I mean let's stop
right exactly
[Laughter]
Smoochy I gotta go take a [__] yeah
really not a different person
um off this than I am on it but I think
that's fairly unusual and calling on the
political Tommy was so I actually like
that I understand why I think there's
something very uh risky about putting
yourself out there the way I have
decided to do but it's what works for me
within certain boundaries of respecting
my family and my other relationships
yeah we don't see it anymore
um Cha-Cha said to me the other day my
13 year old that I use a TV voice when
I'm on the podcast
Cha-Cha named after the slide
okay I'm a big fan Oh I thought I
thought he named her after the [__]
from Greece okay well what are the other
we don't know
on TV I I don't think that's true
just don't curse as much and I'm
speaking to adults
um are you you're on YouTube no you're
not
you're talking to 15 year old girls and
Asians as opposed to like you know
talking [__] with one of them
he's using a TV voice because the
[__] gain on that mic is cranked up
the [__] hell dude yeah yeah but it's
a good mic he just he doesn't have the
board set right you know the fishing
buddies or dressing down my kid or
talking to her about whatever it is you
know then I'm talking like a dad to a
kid as opposed to adult to adult but to
the extent that she's right and I'm just
explaining it away I do try to have as
little artifice as possible so I guess
if you didn't like me maybe you had more
purchase on my personality than would be
true with other TV Talent no yeah you're
different he's he's different he's Come
From a Different Cloth
I like how he still uses the TV ear
monitor to feel like he's special he's
special that's for [__] sure
all right I think I think we have enough
God you're right though he doesn't need
that yeah it's just these things that he
gets because I feel like I'm still in
the business
oh God you're right um I'm a
professional he shows up to interviews
with his own earpiece that he brings
from home